[Applause]
10 on the shot clock
bundy's gonna tack that morris
[Applause]
corner three
off the mark 10 seconds to go
[Applause]
not today buddy
and the nuggets have the w
the second best defensive rating in the
nba this season that's nicola yokish
folks
now we said from about the first quarter
they were led to play and
good challenge actually get out of
gorman's hand
well you know what i think that's pretty
good i wondered at first
jason tate point blank range
and joking gets it out of there
that's that's a clean block
the nuggets pull one out
how about that trailing by five with 2
44 to go
and
aaron gordon hits two
huge threes
jokic with the defensive play of the
game
and the nuggets
improve their record to five and four
the houston rockets go to one and eight
the rockets have now
lost 13 consecutive
road games
all right
right now let's go to kyle speller
now let's send it over to carrie antrio
standing by with number 15 the joking
thank you so much kyle
joe kitch
you guys come in first game of a
five-game home stand how good does it
feel to get that win well it is a tough
game you know we can score a lot we
especially the three 3.1 what was our
enemy today but we keep fighting we were
down in a
on the fourth quarter we came back agent
made the big shots
so yeah i'm just happy that he won the
game
sixth time this season you've held the
opponent to under 100 points what does
that say about your guys defense i mean
we are trying you know we are trying uh
especially at home i think we can we can
do that even even better uh we are
trying to be a good defensive team i
think the defense win championship and
that's what we're trying to do
take us back walk us through that block
there
uh i mean uh the devil had i think 10
seconds in the clock and they were just
attacking they were down one
they were just attacking a good pass to
the
uh gordon he kind of drive pick out the
tate and then how it just happened to be
there you know
first time in the new uniforms is there
going to be a lucky wearing of these who
knows yeah maybe i like those they look
good they look good they do look good
thank you so much thank you thank you
guys that was nicole
in his city edition
uniform a splendid game for joker 28
points
14 rebounds couple of steals and the
defensive play of the afternoon a game
saver yeah
yokish saved the day again
for the good guys final final score
the nuggets win at 95